[Music]
on this wednesday night extreme weather
catastrophes on two coasts we urge
people to please please check with your
neighbors atlantic canada gets slashed
while bc prepares for another punishing
storm justice for a black american
murdered by three white men guilty
guilty guilty i never thought this day
would come why the killer's legal
troubles are far from over
milking it for all it's worth global
news investigates how dairy farmers push
prices to an all-time high
and on a collision course gonna be good
for us
nasa's quest to ram a spacecraft into an
asteroid
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we are watching the flood situation
on two coasts in bc all eyes are on two
wet weather systems moving toward the
waterlogged west coast and across the
country in atlantic canada there is a
super soaker of a storm that has
inundated communities in two provinces
in nova scotia residents living in and
around the town of antigonish are
assessing the damage from the excessive
rain that fell yesterday swamping homes
and washing out roads through rural
areas
portions of the picturesque cabot trail
along the coast of cape breton have also
been cut off after more than 200
millimeters of rain fell in some areas
in southwestern newfoundland four
sections of the trans-canada highway
have been washed out cutting off the
community channel porto basque and the
route from one of the island's ferry
ports
as we saw in british columbia climate
change is making weather systems like
these more intense ross lord starts our
coverage with the unprecedented storm on
the atlantic coast where the rain just
keeps coming
this highway near antagonish nova scotia
is one of dozens in the province either
closed or completely severed there's
eight homes sitting between the two
washouts here so they're sort of
stranded at the moment at the height of
the flood waters in anagonish people in
these mini homes had to be rescued by
boat worked hand in hand along with the
fire services and
and we got her down get those people out
of there and get them up on the dry land
at least
and with the animals and stuff we did
our best to get them all out their homes
and their lives have been knocked off
kilter leaving residents like marie swim
wondering where they'll live i don't
know
we're staying in a motel for a few days
red cross put us up so we're going to
try and clean out but
right now we're not sure
in cape breton washed house threatened
to cut some people off from hospital
access public works planners say in
recent years they've been installing
larger culverts for larger storms but
this one has proven too powerful just
with the sheer magnitude of you know in
some areas excess of 270 millimeters of
rain that
i don't think there's a lot of
preparation that could have
handled that the impacts are compounded
because the storm has now stretched over
several days
less severe here in halifax but in other
parts of the atlantic region people are
still in the thick of it
the west coast of newfoundland and
labrador is also getting hammered the
storm knocking out sections of the
trans-canada highway officials are
considering contingency plans like
redirecting ferry service so the
island's supply chains don't get cut off
it's more the the state of the road
condition in transferring goods and
services from
from puerto rico across the trans-canada
highway but so marine atlantic is in
constant contact with us and multiple
government departments and they'll make
that call also watching closely is the
federal government i know the people of
nova scotia in newfoundland are not
unfamiliar with heavy rainstorms but
this one seems to be particularly
challenging authorities and waterlogged
homeowners say it will take days just to
assess the damage and even longer to
complete repairs
ross lord global news halifax
let's bring in global news meteorologist
anthony fornell anthony we're seeing
incredibly wet weather on two coasts are
these similar storm systems and how much
more rain is still to come
hey robin while these systems are not
directly related they are two separate
entities they do have similarities and i
want to talk about atmospheric rivers
because both of them are just that
rivers in the sky that transport water
vapor from the tropics up into the more
polar regions and as they interact with
terrain in this case perpendicular to
newfoundland and cape breton it delivers
copious amounts of rainfall that is
continuing although now starting to
weaken on the east coast so some good
news as the rain lets up there meanwhile
another round of heavy rain pushing
towards the bc coast this is the first
of three atmospheric rivers that are
going to impact the area over the course
of the next week now at any given time
there are about four or five atmospheric
rivers around the planet most of the
time they're out over the oceans but
occasionally they interact with land and
when you have the rocky mountains like
we have in bc they can rake those clouds
and just deliver incredible amounts of
rain and flooding there's atmospheric
river number two on sunday perhaps more
intense in the storm ahead of us and the
third one may be the strongest yet that
by the middle of next week just
including the first two systems we may
be seeing a hundred to 150 millimeters
of rain for those hardest hit areas even
more as you go up the coast towards
central bc a lot of rain on the way and
freezing levels going up so the snow is
going to begin to melt in the mountains
as well robin
anthony farnell in toronto british
columbians are bracing for that
onslaught of storms and they're not
expected to be as powerful as the system
that flooded parts of the province last
week but there is still concern they
could threaten recovery efforts mike
armstrong reports
there is a value to keeping busy it
keeps your mind from focusing on the
negative
well they are very busy in the community
of arnold bc it's south of abbotsford
tucked up against the u.s border
basically one street with devastation on
both sides
the flooding destroyed the entire first
floor of sandy faber's home keeping busy
keeps her mind off among other things
the weather forecast
you know i don't want to go i don't even
think that like i can't even go there
the people here have lived a trauma some
say the way they think about water has
changed the heavy rain in the forecast
is not good news
people are terrified i saw water rising
up in my back ditch yesterday and i
thought oh my gosh it's coming back
at this point if something happens
people are more prepared resources that
were brought in after the flood are
already here the military has deployed
500 ground troops but some are saying
those resources should have been here
before the flooding british columbia
doesn't have an army base well i haven't
seen the military here but that's just
me
calling in the army is supposed to be a
last resort but it happens over the last
six years in canada the military has
been called in to help with natural
disasters 22 times
now there are two bases in bc but both
are on vancouver island cfb comox is an
air force base and cfb esquimalt is a
naval base army deployments are made out
of alberta cfb edmonton on the other
side of the rockies
the army base in british columbia cfb
chilliwack was shut down in the late 90s
its 4 000 personnel were sent to alberta
quebec and new brunswick
[Applause]
was a controversial decision at the time
and one some would like revisited
there's no doubt about it they should
never have closed chilliwack ever
spencer coyne is the mayor of princeton
bc it's a small town in the mountains
about 200 kilometers east of vancouver
it has been hit hard and coin has
requested the help of the military if it
comes it will be soldiers based in
edmonton help for bc he says should be
closer we're getting hit time and time
again
this summer we called in the army to
help fight fires this fall we're calling
in the army to help us with flooding and
it's on and on and on
back in arnold they keep a list of
things the community needs the army
isn't on it the top of the list is
pretty simple
a hug
mike armstrong global news abbotsford bc
in georgia three white men have been
found guilty in the murder of an unarmed
black man ahmad arbree the jury
deliberated for just 11 hours over two
days in a case that's been viewed as
another test for racial injustice in the
united states jackson prolisco reports
on the verdict and the reaction
we the jury find the defendant travis
mcmichael guilty
in a sweeping indictment of their guilt
the jury convicted travis mcmichael his
father gregory and their neighbor
william bryan of murdering ahmad arbury
outside the court reaction was immediate
guilty as i knew it would justice is
being served
each man faced nine separate charges
travis mcmichael who fatally shot arbery
was the only man convicted on all counts
including malice murder the other men
were found guilty of the lesser felony
murder i never thought this day would
come
but god is good during brief
deliberations the mostly white jury
asked to review key pieces of evidence
including video of the moment when
arbory was fatally shot he moved toward
mr armory with the gun the trial
centered around motive the men claimed
they suspected arbory was responsible
for recent burglaries and were
attempting a citizen's arrest they made
their decision to attack a mod artery in
their driveways
because he was
a black man
running down the street throughout the
trial prosecutors focused on what they
called driveway decisions assumptions
made by the men based on video showing
arbory inside a house under construction
in the months prior turning a mod arbory
into a
victim after the choices that he made
the defense repeatedly stoked public
outrage making racially charged comments
about arbory's appearance with no socks
to cover his long
dirty toenails and complaints about
supporters of the arboree family in the
courtroom we don't want any more black
pastors coming in here for many in this
community the verdict signals that
justice is possible but it does not
bring back a young man who was killed
for committing no crime the spirit of a
mind
defeated the lynch mob
the searing images of arbory's final
moments have forever changed georgia the
state has now repealed a civil war-era
law that allowed for citizen arrests
meanwhile the three men still face a
separate trial on federal hate crime
charges that's set to begin in february
jackson prosko global news washington
there was major progress today in
canada's vaccination campaign clinics
for children aged 5 to 11 are now open
in multiple provinces a therapy dog
named bemal was the on hand in montreal
this morning as the first children lined
up for their shots organizers say
they're doing what they can to make the
experience more kid-friendly
and i thought i would cry but
it's just one needle they put in your
arm and then it's just better now that's
all you just really just have to look
somewhere else don't look at your
vaccination and then it's done before
you know it's done
the house of commons vaccine mandate was
one of several hot topics on parliament
hill today mps gathered for their first
question period since the election and
as michael couture reports the
opposition was on the attack
[Music]
the conservative caucus presented aaron
o'toole with a hockey jersey wednesday
morning setting the tone for another
session of full contact question period
the speech from the throne mentioned
inflation
once shameful just once mr speaker so is
the prime minister having trouble
understanding the concerns of canadian
families or does he just not care
that economic attack was repeated over
and over again and the prime minister
pushed back with a familiar line the
member opposite talked about families
that's exactly why we're moving forward
with 10 a day child care right across
the country it all played out with a
full house of commons something we
haven't seen in 20 months and something
we may not see
if the liberals get their way but mr
speaker we are not out of this pandemic
the government tabled a motion to bring
back hybrid parliament until june 23rd
the conservatives and bloc say it's a
question of accountability we saw
ministers
sitting in their offices avoiding the
scrutiny and the pressure that comes
from actually sitting in parliament the
liberals say it's a question of safety
especially after a member of the
conservatives had a breakthrough case of
covid19
and there continue to be questions about
how many tories are unvaccinated with
medical exemptions
some conservatives left caucus with bags
of covet 19 rapid tests which caucus
chair scott reed says have been made
available for the last month out of an
abundance of caution but that didn't
stop the prime minister from taking a
political pot shot canadians returned us
with a very clear mandate all of us to
end this pandemic once and for all which
happens through vaccinations guys and
that was just the first full day robin
perhaps a signal of what to expect for
the next three and a half weeks
michael couture in ottawa thanks mike
tragedy strikes in the english channel
coming up the dozens of migrants who
perished while on a perilous journey
at least 31 migrants trying to reach the
uk from france died when their boat sank
in the english channel france says it is
the deadliest tragedy involving migrants
at the dangerous crossing it's believed
34 people were on the boat two people
have been rescued a third is still
missing but the search has been called
off five women and a little girl are
among those who died french police
arrested four people with suspected
links to the incident
the covet crisis in europe has hit
another dangerous level with multiple
countries setting new records for daily
cases the czech republic hungary the
netherlands and slovakia all reported
their highest number of daily infections
today with cases surging across europe
more countries are imposing tough new
restrictions slovakia is entering a
two-week lockdown in italy 20 small
towns have imposed an 8 pm curfew france
is expected to reveal new measures later
this week
there was a stark warning today about
the escalating crisis in europe the who
says the region is once again the
epicenter of the pandemic last week
europe accounted for more than 60
percent of all reported cases and deaths
worldwide officials say there's a false
sense of security around vaccines and
even vaccinated people must take more
precautions
even in the midst of a very very strong
resurgence in cases we're seeing
pre-pandemic levels of social mixing
gathering and many other things and and
the reality is the virus will continue
to transmit intensely in that
environment
the eu's public health agency is now
recommending booster shops for all
adults in europe to help protect people
from infection
money milking still ahead why you can
expect to dole out more for dairy in the
new year
[Music]
expect the price of dairy to jump next
year the canadian dairy commission is
proposing a record increase for 2022
farmers would be paid more but the cost
of milk cheese and other canadian dairy
products would go up too critics say the
crown corporation is giving more weight
to producers than consumers when setting
prices eric sorenson has more
if you're worried about rising food
costs get ready for a hike in dairy
products producers have been hit by
higher fuel prices and a big jump for
animal feed it's gone up by 27
and and there's really there's no
shortcuts we can take with that cows
have to be fed to produce milk but the
proposed payments to dairy farmers is
contentious the canadian dairy
commission's usual formula initially
determined a price increase of 6.4
percent according to internal documents
obtained by global news the previous
record increase was 4.5 percent but
dairy farmers felt they needed more and
the commission ultimately recommended
8.4 percent almost double the previous
record
it's necessary to keep up with his costs
says one farmer we're playing catch up
because i've had to pay those costs for
the last six months retailers and
restaurants who will pay more for milk
wanted just a 3.3 percent hike critics
believe decision making at the canadian
dairy commission favors producers under
a supply management regime that already
guarantees those farmers a minimum price
this expert says the cdc needs reform
make it more transparent change the
governance of
the cdc which would include processors
restaurant and consumers as well
give them a voice what about the price
of milk the price of milk is nuts indeed
that's why we're working on
affordability the trudeau government
says dairy farmers are not abusing the
system last year
only about nine percent of them had
revenues over
their expenses so i think the work that
the commission has done
is fair we've also been clearer i mean
this government is going to
protect the supply managed sector but
that sector will usher in milk prices up
to 10 percent higher by some estimates
which would hit hard low-income families
already facing other price increases
these very vulnerable families are going
to be drowning
in increased prices fluid milk is a
staple for canadian diet therefore
there's a social safety net that needs
to be put around this important
product the supply management system
does ensure a safe and adequate supply
of milk for canadians but if provincial
authorities approve new dairy prices
will kick in february first eric
sorensen global news toronto
up next dart defense how nasa's latest
test mission might help save planet
earth
take a look at this dramatic footage of
spain's la palma volcano a new stream of
lava has reached the ocean sending
clouds of potentially toxic gases into
the sky as the volcanic material cools
it extends the island's surface it has
already grown by 43 hectares since the
eruption began just over two months ago
well it may sound like a flashback to a
hollywood blockbuster but nasa's latest
mission is very real the space agency
has just launched dart a spacecraft
designed to smash into an asteroid it's
supposed to test if technology can
actually stop dangerous space debris
from hitting our planet so how worried
should we be mike trolley explains
if you gaze towards space long enough
you're bound to see a shooting star and
as people say make a wish three
two
one
well nasa's latest launch is less about
the things we wish upon and more about
anything we wish will avoid earth
altogether but if there's anything
that's slightly larger so anything
bigger than 30 30 meters in size it
could cause some damage depending on
where it impacts anything that's really
really big bigger than 140 meters in
size so just like a small football
stadium it could be devastating for life
on earth and that's where dart comes in
vehicles supersonic it's a small
spacecraft designed to deliberately
crash into an asteroid as part of nasa's
planetary defense strategy
its target is dimorphous a small
asteroid orbiting a larger one and no
neither is on a collision course with
earth nor is any other large asteroid
they're tracking
this is merely a test to see if they can
alter dimorphous's course so if the
earth was ever in peril we could do
something about it that's how seventy
percent of all life on earth died so if
something of significant size hit us
we're gonna go bye-bye it's not gonna be
good for us
a camera will record darts collision
next september which will no doubt be
thrilling i know they are partying it up
uh wherever they're watching from it
just won't be hollywood thrilling
in fact while dart will collide with
dimorphis at 24 000 kilometers per hour
it will be more like a thud than an
explosion
and maybe then the dart team can let
loose
[Applause]
nasa style
microlight global news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday night i'm robin gill tonight
your canada is the muscadabit river in
nova scotia we would love to see your
corner of the country so please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
we'll be back at the anchor desk
tomorrow and i'll see you again this
weekend have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you